Salut ! Ce matin, je vous ai proposé sur Facebook un jeu, pour que vous puissiez participer à un mentalisation directement par Skype.
Vous avez été tout ça là, à répondre.
Marine,
Sirictor...
Bref ! Je suis en train de plier les petits papiers...
pour tous vous mettre.
Nathalie Ricdand...
C'est long ! J'ai pas du tout prévu ce temps.
And the last !
[mélange les papiers]
Et le gagnant ou la gagnante est...
Flo Lilou.
C'est bon, Flo a accepté ma demande d'ami.
T'imagines c'est la qu'elle te base: "Mais t'es qui toi ?!"
Le nom de Flo, je vais le mettre de coté,
et je vais laisser tous cela, dans ce pot ici
que je vais ranger là-bas.
Et si ça vous tente qu'on refasse des vidéos comme ça, et que vous voulez rejouer, vous aurez déjà votre nom une fois dedans.
Donc 1 chance de plus d'être pioché au sort !
Bon... On a Flo qui est en train de se désister, en fait elle a peur de faire la mentalisation.
Je me rends donc compte que vous flippez que je vous mentalise.
C'est drôle !
Il y a tellement rien à craindre !
Bon, écoute Flo, je comprends il n'y a pas de souci.
Je retourne chercher les petits papiers ! [rires]
Nouveau tirage au sort !
[mélange les papiers]
Attends ! J'en ai fait tombé un.
Je brasse bien !
E le gagnant, la gagnante est Julie Lips !
Julie Lips, à qui je vais envoyer un message sur Facebook et qui j'espère sera connectée, n'aura pas peur, aura Skype et aura 10 minutes. [rires]
J'ai commencé à faire tout ça à 20H45, il est 21H27, et on a toujours pas commencé la vidéo.
Hey !
C'est tellement drôle, parce que juste avant je n'avais pas vu que tu avais répondu que tu boudais sur Facebook.
-C'est vrai, mais attends, mais attends, j'étais au bureau,
et... attends fait voir, là ça fait tout gris c'est bien.
J'étais au bureau et du coup... on me voit bien là ?
Parce que je n'ai jamais skypé j'ai du skypé 3 fois dans ma vie...
J'étais au bureau et du coup je me suis inscrite, j'ai vite connecté Skype et tout avant la réunion,
je suis partie tard de réunion et quand je suis arrivé j'ai vu le résultat, j'ai dit: "Ah c'est même pas moi !"
en plus j'ai prit l'ordi, j'ai tout fait, voilà...
-Je vous présente Julie ! Julie tu habites à ?
-La Rochelle ! Dans le 17.
Et tu travailles ?
Au "Petit zappeur", le magazine.
-Au "Petit zappeur" ?
-Oui.
-Et si je ne dis pas de bêtise, vous étiez venu me voir en spectacle.
-Oui ! Voilà.
-Si tu étais... Tu étais bien avec eux ?
-Enfin, moi j'étais venue avec ma famille, mais ils étaient dans la salle également.
-Cool !
-Et j'ai eu les places via l'entreprise.
-P*****.
Tu connais du monde !
Elle a eu les places via la boite t'as vu !
-La chance !
-[rires] La chance !
-La chance d'assister au concert.
"Au concert" au show plutôt, pardon.
-Non mais je pourrais très bien chanter. Saches que je chante très bien ! [rires]
Saches que j'ai tout à fait les capacités vocales de faire un concert.
J'ai préparé des cartes, des symboles ESP.
Je vous mets une fiche juste ici, pour vous faire voir la vidéo où j'avais fait sur les symboles ESP déjà.
Et ça, je te présente une petite prédiction
que j'ai mis dans une enveloppe.
Alors si je la... Ah ! Mais oui !
[rires]
Je n'ai pas du tout pensé que tu ne vois pas du tout ce que je fais là.
-Non, moi je vois juste que...
jusque... oui voilà. Oui, là je vois maintenant.
-Alors écoutes, je vais disparaître pour laisser place à mes mains, tu ne me verras plus.
Ce n'est pas grave ?
-[rires] Ok !
-Alors je mets la prédiction ici, comme ça elle ne bougera pas.
Et là j'ai donc quelques symboles ESP sur des cartes comme ça.
Je vous fait voir les cartes.
Alors les symboles sont derrière évidemment.
Attends, je mets la prédiction par là.
Tous les symboles là.
Toi, tu dois tout voir. C'est bon.
-Oui.
-Vous, vous voyez tout aussi, c'est bon.
Super !
Dans l'idée, je ne vais pas te demander de choisir un symbole.
Parce qu'on pourrait penser que j'ai regardé sur Facebook ce que tu aimais, que j'ai fait des déductions...
Et que je pourrais anticiper à l'avance la couleur que tu choisi ou le symbole qui t'irais le mieux.
Donc je vais te faire choisir un symbole, mais avec une étape en plus.
Une étape numérique.
L'étape numérique elle est très importante, c'est une étape de correspondance.
Ça ne te parle pas très bien, ça te parlera mieux à la fin.
Est-ce que, en prenant le temps de réfléchir, tu peux me donner un nombre entre 1 et 6 ?
Mais en prenant le temps de réfléchir, il faut que ce soit un vrai choix.
[musique]
-C'est bon.
-C'est bon. Alors je t'écoute.
-Là, je peux te le dire ?
-Oui bien sûr, ouais.
-Le 2.
-Le 2. Ok.
Tu as choisi le 2.
Je vais te faire voir quelque chose, j'espère que tu vois toujours bien et que vous allez aussi bien voir.
Derrière toutes les cartes il y a un chiffre.
En fait l'étoile, c'était le numéro 5.
La croix c'est le numéro 6.
-Le carré c'est le numéro 1.
Le triangle c'est le numéro 4.
Les vagues, le numéro 3.
Et le cercle, le numéro 2.
J'ai fait exprès de ne pas les mettre dans le même ordre.
J'ai vraiment mélangé.
Toi t'as choisi le 2.
Donc la carte numéro 2, c'est ce symbole là.
Je sors juste du champ pour vous faire voir aussi.
La carte numéro 2 c'est ce symbole là
Et je leur fait voir un petit peu les autres.
Voilà, ça c'est le 3.
Ca c'est le 4.
Etc, etc.
Donc tu as choisi le cercle rouge.
Pourquoi tu as choisi le 2 ?
-Je suis née le 20, en février donc le 2,
c'est un chiffre pair et je préfère.
Voilà.
Pas mal de...
-Tu sais que tu viens de caler discrètement ta date de naissance pour qu'on te souhaite un bon anniversaire le 20 février !
Bien joué !
[rires]
C'est très bien joué !
-C'est pour avoir des cadeaux. [rires]
-Donc tu as choisi le cercle rouge.
Ecoute, je te fais voir la prédiction. Je pense que tout le monde voit bien ici et toi aussi.
-Non mais attends, c'est abusé. [rires]
-Il y a une carte et une seule carte parmi les 6 à l'intérieur.
[rires]
Attends, je la laisse bien ici.
Mais en plus tu sais que si tu m'avais demandé un symbole, juste un symbole, c'est pas forcément celui que j'aurai...
-Tu l'aurais choisi ?
Ah non.
[rires]
Je vous fais voire aussi c'est une petite enveloppe... on s'en fiche.
-C'est chiant !
[rires]
Je vous le fais voir.
-C'est étonnant.
-Ah c'est étonnant ? Ah c'est un joli mot, merci !
C'est cool.
Je range toutes mes petites affaires...
Ecoute, je ne sais pas si ça leur plaira ça.
Est-ce que toi ça te plait de participer à ça en fait ? A une vidéo comme ça ?
-Oui, oui, c'est intéressant.
Oui je trouve ça cool.
-Alors dans ces cas là, je le ferai peut-être sur d'autres vidéos.
-Non, je trouve ça bien. Ça fait participer en plus les gens qui te suivent, donc c'est intéressant, et même pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas.
Mais comment t'as fait du coup ? Parce que tu ne me dis pas...
-On sent la meuf qui est dans la communication !
Tu sais "c'est hyper interessant", "ça fait participer les gens qui suivent"...
[rires] C'est les réflexes professionnels.
-Non mais stratégie automatiquement. Non, mais c'est vrai, je trouve ça cool, c'est intéressant et puis du coup ça nous met dedans aussi quoi.
Mais bon, ça ne répond pas à la question comment t'as fait.
-Je peux m'engager.
Je te donnerai les réponses l'année prochaine pour ton anniversaire.
-Tu sais que je n'oublie rien, sinon je boude !
Merci à vous. Si la vidéo avec Julie vous a plu, vous pouvez nous le faire savoir à Julie et à moi en laissant un petit pouce en l'air !
Si ça vous dit qu'on continue à faire ça, des mentalisations par Skype, où je vous fais participer, vous me le dites dans les commentaires.
Et vous pouvez également vous abonner à la chaine, parce que le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Alors rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !
-Au revoir !